tu as repris l'entraînement quoi après
l'accouchement j'ai commencé
tranquillement mais on va dire presque
directement les respirations on verra
dans le livre et après deux semaines
yoga et quelques trois semaines vélo et
judo un mois mes petit à petit pas à
fond directement
si si non mais je sais tu vois quand
elle dit petit à petit sinon on fait le
même entraînement on arrête tout là stop
rideau donc je te dis alors qu'est-ce
que on va voir on va voir ton titre ça a
été incroyable encore je l'ai dit hein
sixième fois pour la 6e fois tu es
championne du monde de judo tu es la
patronne
je peux dire que je suis la patronne
[Applaudissements]
maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors tu as eu cette petite est-ce que
c'est le plus beau c'est le plus beau
parce que ça a été le plus dur c'est ça
tu pensais pas non franchement je me
suis dit que je suis pas à 100% ça va
être compliqué ça va être chaud ça va
être chaud je peux avoir une médaille
mais de la gagner il disait quoi les
entraîneurs
ils avaient confiance ou il disait on va
essayer mais ça va être dur eux ils
disent rien et jamais rien et après mon
entraîneur il avait confiance mon
entraîneur
ce qui est fou c'est que ce type de
champion du monde on l'a dit c'était
moins d'un an après avoir accouché
franchement c'est pour ta petite fille
j'ai tout donné pour elle j'entendais
aller fais-le pour Athéna
c'est un modèle à la fois une sportif
peut-être une des plus grandes sportives
de tous les temps tout sport français
confondu et puis un modèle aussi de
d'engagement toujours positif un
engagement sociétal pour les enfants
prématurés vous êtes très impliqué donc
c'est une femme exemplaire à l'image du
livre qui donne plein de conseils qui
permet d'être positif et de progressé je
suis pas une maman sportive mais en
lisant on a envie de faire des choses
[Rires]
un modèle unicône voilà merci beaucoup
je te jure tu es vraiment mais vous avez
vu tu es magnifique
on peut être une énorme une immense
sportive c'est ce que tu dis et être
maman maman est sportive on va revenir
sur ce livre qui a écrit avec la docteur
Bernadette de Gasquet actuellement
disponible aux éditions Marabout
pourquoi pourquoi tu as fait si pour
voilà pour donner envie à toutes les
mamans aussi de se dire voilà on peut on
peut être maman peut être féminine et on
peut être une grande sportive c'est ça
c'est vrai que c'est difficile et quand
moi j'ai repris j'ai été content d'avoir
Bernadette qui me donnait des conseils
donc fais attention fais attention quand
tu vas reprendre on n'a pas envie que tu
retournes en arrière ou que tu te fasses
pipi dessus en faisant une prise de judo
donc forcément quand elle m'a proposé ça
je me dis c'est parfait parce que moi je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas trouvé moi-même
j'ai de la chance de la connaître donc
d'avoir ce livre c'est vraiment pour
toutes toutes les femmes que ça soit
d'un niveau ou juste aller chercher des
choses ou porter ses enfants c'est
comment porter ses enfants correctement
comment revenir pour pour marche ou des
choses comme ça ou aller à faire des
sports de haut niveau donc c'est
vraiment fait pour tout le monde le but
c'est de reprendre le sport après une
grossesse voilà et ça c'est important
exactement
elle est grande elle a presque 20 ans
mais en fait je l'ai lu aussi et j'ai vu
tous vos conseils pour rester en forme
pour rester un peu musclé pour être
gainé plein d'exercices qui paraissent
plutôt facile au quotidien pour le mal
de dos pour la posture comment se tenir
quand on est assis pendant tous les
jours donc des plans de petits conseils
et moi j'ai trouvé ça vraiment
formidable et super intéressant à tous
les niveaux qu'on soit les championne
comme vous un peu sportif comme moi pas
du tout sportif comme Daniel enfin voilà
tous les quatre fois de piscine
j'ai trouvé que c'était super et vos
conseils aussi pour l'allaitement j'ai
trouvé ça très beau et très émouvant
ce qu'il faut dire aussi pour les gens
qui nous regardent qui voudraient
acheter le le livre c'est que c'est pas
réservé aux supersportif c'est-à-dire
que même si on fait un peu de vélo 10
minutes par jour le matin voilà et qu'on
n'est pas un grand grand sportif moi par
exemple et ben on y trouve des conseils
notamment sur la respiration aussi
comment gérer son sens c'est important
la respiration oui c'est vrai bien sûr
et c'est vrai que tu veux dire aux
femmes que c'est possible donc de
conjuguer comme l'a dit maternité et
aussi grande carrière sportive après
voilà on peut faire du sport quand on
est maman on n'est pas obligé d'être une
immense championne voilà comme comme
Klein c'est ça alors
un de tes plus grands exploits c'est
aussi bien sûr cette médaille d'or aux
JO de Tokyo tu étais d'ailleurs porte
drapeau aux JO et tu remportes l'or
c'est complètement fou j'aimerais qu'on
revoit ce moment parce que pour nous
tous c'était un moment je suis surgile
d'émotion exceptionnelle
elle a besoin que d'une attaque là elle
est placé
[Applaudissements]
la colonne entre les deux championne la
championne olympique en titre quelle
puissance
[Applaudissements]
c'est ma plus belle ça a été difficile
avec l'année avec le coït on a eu 5 ans
au lieu de 4 et je la retrouve en finale
alors qu'elle m'a battue à 5 ans je me
suis dit ah c'est chaud là
tu sais même pas c'est lui qui est le
premier qui marque un point je te jure
c'est un stress moi sur Teddy j'ai eu
tellement peur parce qu'à un moment il y
avait eu un truc il y avait un il y a
une nouvelle règle qui dit que ce qu'a
fait l'adversaire de Teddy n'était pas
homologué voilà mais un moment j'ai cru
qu'il allait perdre parce que c'est vrai
que golden score c'est c'est un enfer je
sais pas comment vous faites parce que
c'est c'est un stress puis tu fais une
petite erreur tu peux passer à côté
c'est fini et pourtant là je me suis dit
golden score je vais gagner c'est
bizarre
elle va finir par craquer ça dans la
tête
dans la tête parce que tu as gagné aussi
donc tu es consciente que tu es devenu
un symbole parce que tu as eu aussi un
truc c'est que maintenant il y a ta
statue
ils ont pris le temps et j'étais
enceinte en plus donc c'était assez
orange j'aurais dit me fait pas trop
gros
[Rires]
incroyable non ils étaient super
contents ils sont fiers de toi ça me
ressemble bien non franchement
c'était vu quand vous étiez enceinte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
de tout son engagement pour les femmes
pour les enfants etc il avait pas
remarqué que j'étais enceinte vous étiez
ensemble et et est-ce que le mental
parce qu'on dit souvent quand on devient
maman justement ça donne plus de force
et ce que justement vous l'avez ressenti
vous pour l'énorme énormément de toute
façon en plus moi je suis fatigué au
quotidien ou et je trouve quand même de
la force pour pour me lever pour
m'entraîner en vrai donc après ça dépend
il y a des moments où ça va mais là
j'avoue que je commence à fatiguer et
parce que je fais beaucoup de choses
aussi entre il y a pas que les
entraînements qui qui font mais et puis
j'allais encore un peu la nuit donc
c'est le sport